[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony
[Music]
[__] with the cousin [__] heing the
cousin [__] there oh my
God cousin [__] fascist right they
want to bang their
[Music]
family his name is Nick Wilson he was on
Survivor I guess I guess it qualifies
him to be some sort of state
representative in Kentucky I thought it
was Tennessee this morning in the
producers corner I was like into
Tennessee they're like no Kentucky I'm
like yeah you know whatever same thing
can
Tennessee of course of course uh a
republican manga politician in a state
legislator puts forth the bill that
makes it legal to [__] your first cousin
that's a real thing that just that that
had just happened in this
country now apparently he was tricked
into it at least that's what they claim
which doesn't really make it any better
right it doesn't make it any better but
he was maybe tricked into supporting a
bill where you could have sex with with
your first
cousin so in Missouri they want to check
children's genitalia before going into
bathrooms that's a [__] thing they're
trying to pass a bill in Missouri hell
I'll show you a goddamn video of it
today if you'd
like um also Nick Wilson state
representative state senator some [__] I
don't know I typed in his name in
Google I'm not kidding you I diped in
his name and it says
uh here I'll just [__] it I'll just I'll
tweet the son [__] um I'll tweet the
son [__] and I'll show it to you and
the reason why is
because oh MAA every single [__] time
every time they do something that you're
like can it get stupid or can it get
dumber than it already is surely they're
not surely they're not going to do the
whole writing a
bill uh where they want to [__] their
cousins
right
maybe maybe maybe
not they are they're they're definitely
going to write bills where they can [__]
their cousins at least get tricked into
it um here is the um here I'll I'll show
you this here I'll put it up on the
screen here's a let's do it like this
there it is um I typed in Nick Wilson in
Google and it says Nick Wilson Kentucky
state representative Nick Wilson
Survivor he was on the show Survivor
apparently Nick Wilson Kentucky state
representative this it gets better Nick
Wilson cousin Nick Wilson Kentucky
cousin Nick Wilson Bill Nick Wilson Bill
cousin Mick Wilson cousin [__] law it
doesn't say bucking but you I made that
part up but what do you want from
me what do you want from me I didn't do
this to them they do this to themselves
I mean Trump's got [__] syphilis
right Trump's got syphilis or the clap
what whatever and some sort of sexually
transmitted
disease and a republican in Kentucky
named Nick Wilson is trying to [__] his
cousin in Missouri they're trying to
inspect children's genitalia before they
go into the bathroom in elementary
schools they're banning Women's Health
Care all across the country trying to
ban the privacy of women in in a
doctor's office they're trying to take
away consent from parents like what
books they can read what books they
can't [__]
read I mean what do you think what do
you think feeling up children in an
elementary
school because they're scared of they're
scared of certain genitali C this is so
[__] dumb what when when did
bathrooms become
taboo I know I know it feels like
because you
know you have to you know take a piss or
take a [__] but when did it become
taboo right I mean listen I've went to a
gas station before and had to take a
[__] I mean like you know what I'm
talking about you didn't think you were
going to make it you're on the road your
stomach's
like got to take a [__] now you know
what I mean maybe you had Chinese for
lunch or something and it just didn't
sit well so you're trying to make it to
the next gas station of
otherwise you're you're you're going to
need a grandpa poopy pants type diaper
change right you've probably been in the
situation before and you get in the gas
station and the [__] bathroom that
you want to go in is
locked
uhoh and it's an emergency you know what
I mean like either you're going to [__]
in that other bathroom that isn't the
gender that you are or you're going to
[__] your pants right there in the gas
station when did it be become taboo that
you have to go into a certain room with
a certain sign on it you know these are
the same [__] these are the
same [__] that are always like
oh you think your you think your little
gun sign that you can't bring guns in
here is g to protect
you literally it is a [__] room with
a toilet in it one's got one sign on it
with a certain emblem the other one's
got the other one that's it that's all
it is dumbest [__] I've ever heard of in
my life I've never ever ever
ever went into a bathroom taking a [__]
in the stall and thinking about the
person's genit Alan next to me not until
these [__] started saying this
[__] out loud did I ever think about
that and I'm sure you didn't either
because it's [__]
weird it's weird that they come up with
this stuff
even I mean just just take the bathroom
bill um you know take the whole they
want to molest children because that's I
mean they want to marry children in
Missouri we know we know that there was
a state senator last year that filed a
bill that he wanted to make sure that
parents could consent for 12 year olds
to get [__] married I said it yes a
republican a
Mite a cousin [__]
fascist wanted to make sure that a
12-year-old in the state of Missouri
could get married and they're not
talking about a boy they're not talking
about a 12-year-old boy oh they wouldn't
let a 12-year-old boy get married no no
they wouldn't let a 12-year-old boy get
married that take away his manhood and
all this you know chest thumping
[__] they're talking about little
girls so just take the the they want to
marry children they want to molest
children at schools because they want to
say well I don't know if they're at
gender or not
so what they're really doing is is
taking away the consent of parents okay
that's what they're really
doing they want to take your [__]
consent
away they the [__] cousin [__]
fascist the kid Maran fascist want to
take your [__] consent
away just like Nick Wilson was easily
tricked into sponsoring a cousin [__]
bill in Kentucky these people aren't
being tricked into these bills where
they're banning women's
healthare they're criminalizing
pregnancies there's certain types of
pregnancies and a woman can never tell
you know what I mean it's not like when
a woman gets pregnant and she finds out
she's pregnant she's like you know what
I think I'm going to make this pregnancy
have complications I think I'm going to
do that just because you know that's
what I want for my
health nope that's not how it works you
[__]
boneheads you're criminalizing certain
pregnancies that a woman can't control
she can't maybe she wants to have a
[__]
baby you ever think about
that Mr Force berther previously a
prolifer huh
prolife and if you don't think that this
is an easy easy layup to mock them with
this cousin [__]
you're not
[Music]
paying it is kind of like
Deliverance squee like a
pig
that's I I I can't tell you you know we
we we sit here every day we mock these
idiots they say stupid [__] at rallies
they they they puke up fascist word
salad they read from their Facebook
feeds
they spout off Q andon just crazy ass
qinon conspiracy theories like Obama's
running the country and Joe Biden's not
real and he's actually dead it's James
Woods who's playing him and Trump's the
[__] president and all kinds of weird
ass
[__] and they give us a layup a layup of
Republicans trying to make it to where
you can [__] your first cousin in
Kentucky
and make it
legal because I I apparently in Kentucky
it is illegal to [__] your first
cousin I don't know if every red State's
like that I doubt
it I don't know I live I live in the
Attic of
Arkansas in
Missouri I mean it it is kind of the
attic of Arkansas and down there in
Arkansas I don't know if you know who
their governor is but Sarah [__]
Sanders um not only does she buy $7,000
podiums but I'm sure I'm sure her cousin
Daryl has caught her eye a time or
two wouldn't that be funny if she
actually had a cousin named Daryl she
probably does she's from Arkansas she
definitely has a [__] cousin named
Daryl any Daryl's out there in the
audience I apologize that name does not
mean that you automatically are cousin
[__] but if you are from Arkansas and
your name is
Daryl what the hell do you want from me
your parents did that [__] not
[Laughter]
me the Tony Michaels podcast it's Friday
we got bone of the week of course we're
gonna mock these son of a [__] on
Friday bonee head of the week and I got
my new merch shirt on look at that [__]
this machine kills fascist it's a shirt
here the back you see the back there I'm
really excited about the shirt I got
this shirt I got my hoodie um that I'm
going to give to uh the artist for the
tattoo which I want to I want to thank
everyone right now um who has went and
who has contributed to the tattoo uh
team team tattoo fund all that money
that you guys have put into the team
tattoo fund not only you're going to get
to see me live stream when I get my
tattoo I'm actually hoping I'm actually
hoping that it hurts and you guys get to
see me like wse and hert a little bit
I'm hoping so
no I'm I'm serious because I you know if
if it doesn't really hurt or anything
then you guys are going to kind of be
disappointed
I you might hear me squeal like a pig
when I'm doing the uh when I'm doing the
tattoo so so if you guys if you guys
contributed to the team tattoo fund I
want to thank you uh we're we're at like
over 35% of the goal right now I think
it's like if there's if there's 15
people 15 people that get $25 or 20
people that give 20 bucks I think
there's no way that we're not going to
hit this goal and again all the money
that goes to that let me let me show you
the um if you go to the Tony
michaels.com and you pan on down uh it's
the very first link there it says C
tattoo live stream you can put any
amount in this team tattoo fund um
rather it's a dollar $10 $20 $15
whatever you want to put in there I'm
going to put you on a signup sheet that
is going to email you the links um to
the live stream so you'll get them in
your email remember that whatever email
you used to put money in the team tattoo
fund then what you're going to do is
you're going to um receive an email
there for the live streams and that's
next Friday so we got till next Friday
um to to get hit our goal and again I
think it's like 15 people 25 bucks 20
people 20 bucks something like that uh
we'll hit the goal easy peasy stuff um
and then again if you want to go in
there and just do$ two doll a dollar $5
doar just to get on the list to see the
live stream go do that that you got to
put it in this fund you got to click
this link to get on that live stream
link list because that's where I'm going
to send it from so um that's where I so
all the money that goes into that fund
is going to go directly to the artist
the artist and probably next week I'll
I'll introduce the artist to you guys on
like social media and stuff so you go
look at his work um I'm gonna have a
consultation with him on I think Sunday
or Monday I believe this weekend so over
the weekend I'll I'll have a
consultation with him and then U I'll
probably send the the design to that
email list um from Team tattoo so you'll
get the the exclusive content as it goes
on I'm super excited about it I I really
am um I'm so excited to get that on my
arm permanently so no one can so no one
can take it away from us because it
means a lot to me and I know it means a
lot to you guys uh for this microphone
to stay powered on this microphone stay
powered on against fascism that way you
with your thousands of microphones can
go spread the message and spread the
narrative and we had the producers
Corner this morning we're having a
little bit of trouble with the producers
corner I don't know what's going on with
it over there um so if you are signed up
for the producers corner it's it's an
hour before the show so it's just a
conversation that we have before the
show uh every Monday and Friday it's for
an hour okay and sometimes I'm late I
was a little late this morning I open
the room in time I just I didn't get to
my my studio in time so but there was a
little problem with it but if if you're
having problems just message one of us
uh on Discord one of the moderators or
something and we'll try to get you in
there there's a few people that couldn't
get in the room today but we're going to
try to get that fixed but if you want to
join the producers Corner every Monday
and Friday what you do is you go to
Theon michaels.com pan on down and you
can join the patreon just get you a $20
membership at the patreon and you can
join the producers Cor Corner every
single Monday and Friday you go to the
$20 the $20 tier on patreon and you get
to join the producers Corner every
Monday and Friday it's fantastic and um
yellow Camino I think's the account name
that came in this morning she was
talking about how um she liked how I
spoke about women's rights and I spoke
about Women's Healthcare um because I
don't say the word smm Moran I don't say
Smith Moran I I don't even say that word
very rarely will you hear me say the
word abortion very rarely because it's
not about abortion it's just like the
bathroom [__] it's just like the
bathroom stuff right that [__] ain't
about the
bathroom really honestly it's not even
it's not even about trying to check
children's genitalia which is [__]
weird that's [__] weird I don't care
I don't care what kind of context you
give it outside of a doctor's office
okay if it's not in a doctor's office in
the setting where a medical professional
is doing a medical exam a medical exam
because of some medical reason not
because someone's got to take a [__]
okay they're wanting to check in
Missouri they're wanting to pass a
bill I mean they want to pass a bill to
[__] their cousins in Kentucky but in
Missouri they want to pass a bill where
they can check teachers administrators
can check students children's
genitalia because they got to go
pee okay there it's not a medical re
there's not a medical reason to do this
there's
not and a lot of schools in Missouri
don't even have a full-time nurse I
don't know if a lot of people don't know
that you guys still have School nurses
at your school in Missouri there's the
education funding is so low that some of
those School nurses have to travel from
school to school to school
because they ain't got enough money to
pay to have a nurse at each School the
entire day the whole time because
Republicans in Missouri control the
state and they control the [__]
school
funding but they want to make sure
someone can feel up your kid and they
don't have to be trans what what what
makes them have to be trans but that's
the point that's their [__] point
they want to rule over you they want to
have power over you
and your children they want to take away
your [__] consent because they're
white Christian nationalist listen it's
a [__] disease honestly white
Christian nationalism at this point I'm
beginning to think it's a [__] mental
disorder and we need some [__] mental
health care in this goddamn country and
we need everyone to get some [__]
mental health care
quick because this white Christian
nationalism is getting out of [__]
control when they want to not only get
rid of the schools but then when the
schools that they have they want to be
able to feel the children
up before they take a leak are you
[__] [__]
me again how did bathrooms get so
[__] Taboo in the first
place besides with these
[__] white Christian
nationalists but it's all about taking
away your consent it's all about taking
away your rights that's what fascism
does it's what they do that's what they
want to do and they're not GNA stop at
at roie Wade right they're not going to
stop at Banning women's privacy in a
doctor's office they're not going to
stop at Banning a child's privacy in a
[__] school
bathroom okay they're not going to stop
there they're going to criminalize
pregnancy soon and they're already
talking about it they're already talking
about it with this Taylor Swift stuff
they're already [__] interjecting it
into the public discourse
online and in these these inel
circles with these cousin [__]
fascist everywhere these especially
these fragile white men I am so sick and
tired of this [__] where men who think
they support Trump and manga think
they're [__] tough they think they're
[__] tough and they think because
they [__] they they they want to cast
out Americans they want cast out other
human beings like trans people because
they're not comfortable with someone
else you are a bunch of goddamn [__]
okay you're a bunch of [__] [__]
if you can't handle someone else's
existence You [__] goddamn snowflakes
what the [__] is it any of your goddamn
business what someone is what they want
to be who they love how they dress what
the [__] is it your business and if you
give a [__] that much about it why why
are you even
speaking
why I'm I'll I'll show you where it's
all coming from oh I forget the guy's
name I forget his [__] name does it
really he's an MMA
fighter real tough guy you know he's got
the cauliflower ear oh and I'm sure he's
just a tough [__] oh yeah I'm
sure he's just
tough oh you'll kick your ass Tony yeah
where I come from where I come from I
wouldn't play fair okay I don't play
fair with [__] cousin [__] fascist
okay that's not how it works with
me but goes on goes on [__] total
anti-r anti-gay
tyraids attacking Shan Strickland is his
name Shan Strickland I'll show you the
I'll I'll show you this video of this
guy he's a tough guy oh he's so tough so
[__]
tough it's not tough it's not manly it's
not
masculine it's weak it's a weakness your
white Christian nationalism your little
[__] your little [__] fragile
white male incel privilege H it's a
[__] weakness
okay trust
me it's a [__]
weakness you don't look tough you don't
sound tough if I mean the tough thing is
actually [__] standing up for someone
and a group of people who are trying who
are trying to be eradicated in some of
these [__]
States listen Sean Strickland they want
to feel up children that's where you're
at you're on their side you dumb
[__] talk about grooming goddamn
I don't know how many times I don't know
how many [__] times I've gotten that
typed in comments or threads or [__]
direct
messages look at the
churches look at the white Christian
nationalism that is rotting the brains
of our society the brainworms that come
along with white Christian nationalism
where they want to pass bills in
Kentucky where the [__] their
cousins they want to pass bills in
Missouri where they can feel up children
in
schools they want to ban women's privacy
in their doctor's
office the nais want that like the
actual Nazis the ones that stand on
overpasses in Florida and how Hitler and
support Ronda santz because he he loves
to ostracize the lgbtq community
especially trans kids oh man that Ronda
Sanz likes to pick on more than trans
kids he'll say more bad [__] about trans
kids than the [__] 991 felony count
GR Grandpa Hitler that he's running
against he'll say way more way worse
[__] oh he loves attacking
them loves attacking
them you're a Nazi you're a [__]
Nazi and it's not it's not it's not a
strength to attack a group of people a m
especially such a small group of people
like trans children you [__] weak
pieces of
[__] and to go after women's criminalize
their [__] they want to criminalized
pregnancies in Missouri too and they
want to marry
children and I know it's kind of like my
state but you don't think they're
thinking about this [__] in other states
oh they're hoping this stuff passes in
Missouri [__] yeah because then they can
out Missouri Missouri they can out
Florida Florida they can out Texas Texas
hell Texas the governor of Texas is
murdering women and children at the
border drowning them in the [__]
River with a razor wire murder murder
[__] State sanction Greg Abbott
cousin [__] fascist
murder but yeah go on go on about how
you're worried about the way someone
looks to go into a bathroom okay all
right we see what your priorities are we
know what your aim is
here we know what you're trying to
normally
I we get it we see it it's
clear you're insecure you're
projecting you're a bunch of [__]
groomers you want to marry children you
want to murder children at the border
because they're brown you want to murder
their mother because she's
brown you want to marry you want to
marry your cousin you want to [__] your
cousin you want to make syphilis great
again you want to feel up children in
elementary schools before they go into
the bathroom because you're insecure
about someone else's genitalia it's
weird stuff man it's weird
stuff weird
stuff but it's MAA so we should not be
surprised we shouldn't be surprised but
you should not be surprised because it's
Friday so it's going to be bone end of
the week that's right the guy with the
last name Sanchez is here because it is
Friday and we will have bone head of the
week and I got plenty of Clips to show
you apparently they're going to try to
keep the government open I don't know if
Mike Johnson's going to be the speaker
again we'll see that I've got a great
song for you from Tennessee Brando
called downwind of Donnie I can't wait
to show you that today either and I want
to show you this clip of Sean Strickland
being a weak piece of [__] and also I
want to show
you Republicans trying to defend a bill
where they want to feel up children in
Missouri before they take a
piss all this right after these messages
don't go anywhere we'll be right back de
Tony Michaels podcast right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I Ain even seen my
cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours tamy
[__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__] them
[__] we're back to the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast all right so just this week we
have we have cousin [__] we have
syphilis Grandpa syphilis what else do
we have we got Republicans in Missouri
trying to feel up children cuz they want
to go to the bathroom in
schools Jesus [__] Christ manga on a
roll this week they're on a [__] roll
whoosh all right well let me show you
this um oh this is the um this is Shan
Strickland he pointed he posted this a
couple days ago he posted this this is
someone else post this he posted this to
his Twitter account like he's proud of
this [__] right and he thinks ah he
thinks he's such a [__] tough guy
here you look at his shirt it says a
woman in every kitchen a gun in every
hand ha that's what his shirt
says a woman in every kitchen a gun in
every hand n you know it's his right to
be a stupid [__] you know what I mean
it's his Liberty to be a dumb
[__] rules this guy is more than
welcome to be a just a complete [__]
eater you know what I mean that's your
Liberty but I also have the liberty of
calling you out you [__] little [__]
you weak piece of [__] you weak piece of
[__] and a lot of people are gonna be
like oh Tony he can whip your ass he
might whip my ass in a sanction fight he
might he might whip my ass in a sanction
fight
maybe maybe my guess is is he's just a
little
[__] because of how he [__] treats
people and how he views the world listen
uh we've got a pretty supportive game
lesbian community in this city I did
want to ask you about something you
wrote A couple of years ago you said if
I had a gay son I would think i' another
another I'm saying a swamp you guys a
swamp you become a champion
become
swamp it's obvious that he's Gott hit in
the head a little bit too many times the
swamp all right you wrote a statement
you wrote a demonizing the lgbtq
community saying that about your son
being gay the journalist is going to ask
you a question because you're in a city
where there is a very very very very
popular lgbtq Community he's asking you
a question and he his best retort is
swamp that's his best
retort let me ask you something are you
are you are you
gay are you let me know are you gay can
can I get answer well no I'm asking this
is the part of are you are you a gay man
I'm an ally of the community okay if you
had a son and he was like you know you
had a son he was gay you'd be like oh
man you don't you don't want a grandkid
no problem with it oh man well dude
you're a weak [__] man dude oh oh I
see I see he's a weak man for loving his
son for who his son is I mean I'm sure
this guy who's got the shirt on that
says uh a woman in every K kitchen a gun
in every hand I'm sure he'd be okay with
you know I maybe his son unal living
himself because you know he just he
can't handle who his son would be he
can't handle it he can't handle it and
and the [__] the journalist asking
the question is
weak listen I'm sick of this [__]
[__] where these these [__] who think
they're [__] tough guys attacking
attacking attacking their own [__]
children he's saying if I had a son who
was gay [__]
him you can't get more white male
privilege fragile white male privilege
than this
[__] what a bunch of goddamn [__] you
can't stand up for [__] women's
rights you can't stand you can't stand
up for for lgbtq rights you can't stand
up for other people's [__] Liberty
and you want me to believe that you're
some kind of [__] tough guy that's
what you want me to believe because your
toxic masculinity tells you that how you
make sure that you seem masculine is to
attack marginalized
groups and you think that's
tough okay you puss let's let's hear
what else the [__] weak [__] you got
to say you're like you're part of the
[__] problem you elected Justin Chau
like would you [__] when he sees the
bank accounts like you're just [__]
pathetic and and the fact that the fact
that you have no [__] backbone and
and has he shut down your [__]
country and sees bank accounts what the
[__] is he even talking about Justin
Trudeau and bank accounts you see this
[__] do you see the [__] do you see how
these people devolve into this delusion
into this trap yeah the swamp or you're
weak cuz you won't stand up for your own
son your own child you won't stand up
for him so that makes you weak and then
he goes on about Justin
Trudeau and and and bank accounts what
the [__] is he talking about you ask me
some stupid [__] like that go [__]
yourself move the [__] on man the
question but I didn't want to ask he
looks like he's really uncomfortable
doesn't it because the journalist he
thought he thought the journalist would
shut the [__] up cuz he's he's a tough
guy remember with the cauliflower ear
and [__] you know it's like a like a
[__] branding tag about how tough he
is
probably but the journalist didn't back
down oh and some people are pointing out
that the fight was in Toronto yeah fine
the fights in Toronto I don't give a
[__] it's this tough guy attitude
because this [__] bleeds all over the
world there are no [__] boundaries
anymore of these [__] ideas There's
No Boundaries or B ERS of stupidity
Jesus Christ you got [__] people in
Canada wearing muga hats make America
great again in
Canada and you don't think this shit's
gonna leak down into wherever however
whoever with the bunch of [__] incels
keep going look at him uncomfortable
look at him because he won't he won't he
won't listen to what he says listen next
fight they'll have to accept me or
denounce me when uh when they know what
and will know what they stand for this
guy's like this Canadian is not that
Canadian are you still going to use your
fight time to kind of speak on that
here's the thing about Bud Light oh yeah
what's the thing here's thing about Bud
Light
yeah years ago to be a mental [__]
illness and now all of a sudden no no no
no no no no no no no wait wait wait no
what what it was 10 years ago there was
trans people 10 years ago there was
trans people 20 years ago and 30 years
ago and 100 years ago and 150 years ago
trans people have been around since I
don't know
humans now there was never the science
to where people could actually
transition there is that now we know
certain things
now unbeknownst to this [__] [__]
eater the majority of the trans
Community the more the majority of the
trans Community can grow a better beard
than he can because the majority of the
trans community and I didn't know this
until these [__] shiters started
trying to take away these people's
Liberty
I was not concerned about the trans
Community I did not think they were a
threat to my whiteness or my
masculinity I don't worry about seeing a
beautiful woman and think about what she
got a
wiener like this [__] this
scared piece of
[__]
but to attack them listen to what he
says go ahead you can see where his fear
is at his fear is this guy's fear this
Shan Strickland's fear is that he'd like
[__] that's his fear that Sean
Strickland is really scared that he
would take home a beautiful woman she
would get her dick out it would be
bigger than his and he would love to
suck it that's what he's scared of
listen to him and people like you have
[__] weasel your way in the
world you you are you are an
infection you are the definition of
weakness everything that is wrong with
the world is because of [__] you and
the best thing is is the world's not
buying it the world's not buying your
[__] [__] your [__] pedling
the world is not saying you know what
you're right [__] chicks have dicks
the world's not saying that world's
saying no there are two genders chicks
stab dicks he's terrified he's
terrified
terrified of being attracted to a woman
and she have a dick he's terrified of it
he's terrified that it would make him
feel the gay feelings that he probably
feels it would make him want to suck her
dick and he just might do it if he had
the chance he just he just might suck it
and he just might put it in him if he
got the chance because boy she's good
looking but we just can't have that
that's what they're [__] terrified of
that's what they're scared of that's
what all the hate is drawn
from every [__] last bit of it is
they're terrified that they'd be gay
that they would I I'm not one of them no
and and and that whole thing where a man
looks like a woman and I want to [__]
that woman and she's got a weener that
makes me gay and I can't have
that the entirety the entirety of the in
the in complete Insanity that they want
to eradicate they're saying you're
disease you're vermin you're poisoning
blood you're the problem they want to
eradicate lgbtq people all of them
because they might just be
one [__] piece of [__] [__] Sean
Strickland I don't know who the [__]
this guy is and I don't know who the
[__] he thinks is but listen just shut
up and [__] dribble you [__]
just shut up and [__] they say that
about [__] black black athletes all
the time you know what I mean oh yeah oh
yeah LeBron James shut up and dribble
Colin Kaepernick shut up and [__]
dribble Jesus Christ even Taylor Swift
she's not a black man but she's a
woman might as well shut up and sing
[__] shut up and fight [__]
shut up and get your [__] head
knocked in sounds like you need to get
it knocked in a couple more [__]
times if you want to know the God's Hest
truth cuz I don't know [__] about this
guy I don't give a [__] about him I
don't give a [__] about his fights and
honestly I can't believe that there is a
[__] professional League out there
that would watch someone sit there and
say that type of
[__] but apparently there is with the
UFC because that's who they've attracted
that's the audience that they've
attracted um love always wins says
actually Tony he loves the dick he
probably does he probably loves the dick
and that's why he's saying this stuff
because he doesn't want anyone to know
because he's very embarrassed because he
thinks it makes him weak that he loves
Co
why why I mean dude te it own if you
want to if you want to suck a dick suck
a dick man as long as it's consensual
and everyone's in on it there's not any
shame in it Sean there's not any shame
in you Goblin [__] man it's not a shame
it [__] [__] record it and make a sex
tape put it on social media hell we
might know who you
are go viral we might know who you
are
it's [__]
ridiculous and yeah a lot of people
would hear M banter about it about him
and they'd be like oh Tony you're a
you're a
homophobe listen if you w to win if you
want to win you got to stop being a
[__] like this guy you got to stop
doing that [__] you got to stop doing
that [__] you have to [__] you have
to attack these people the way that they
need to be attacked I am [__] sick
and tired of hearing that you can't fat
shame Donald Trump get the [__] out of
here with that
nonsense that you can't you can't body
shame certain [__] people who have
power you can punch up and we need to be
punching up a lot this [__] is
sitting at a press conference with a
goddamn microphone that says UFC on it
you don't get more punching up than
that [__] [__] loving son of a [__]
all right let's move on Sean Strickland
apparently
he's he's part of the new Confederacy
I'm sure this is the Confederacy that
he's a part of I'm sure he loves this
Confederacy all right yeah
whatever let's go to the Missouri Bill
where they wanna they want to um they
want to molest children that going into
the
bathroom I'm not making that [__]
up it it I'm I don't do this stuff I
just [__] show you the tape of what
they're doing um here is and his name is
Christen long
longsdale he's a republican of course in
Missouri and he does know [__] about his
bill and the reason why he does know
[__] about his bill is because someone
else wrote it someone else actually
wrote it wrote the Bill so he didn't
know [__] about it but here he is um in
the front of a committee where he has to
explain his bill to other
lawmakers of course it's on film and
Laura Burkhart has watched this film so
I'm going to give her credit here um but
listen listen to the back and forth this
is oh man this is wild stuff listen to
this I'm curious um if you're familiar
with the Missouri Supreme Court decision
from 2019 uh RAV Blue
Springs not okay I'm curious how many
times on average would you say you use a
bathroom every day
I don't know three times you should
hydrate
um um are you familiar with title seven
title seven law I'm not are you familiar
with the fact that title seven law and
title n law are generally read together
when it comes to
definitions uh I not okay oh oh so and
it it continues on like this I'm going
to I'm going to show you more of this
but the fact of the matter is is this
person is introducing a bill and
sponsoring a bill that will allow
administrators and Educators to do
[__] genital checks on children
before they go into a
bathroom Okay children children little
kids they are saying that little kids
trans or not trans there's such a risk
of little kids being predators in a
[__] bathroom that adults have to
check their [__]
genitalia okay that wrap your [__]
mind around this we're talking about any
schoolage children from kindergarten to
senior and high school that they are
taking the consent away from parents for
there to be a medical check from a
non-medical professional because my kid
needs to take a piss you're [__] out
of your goddamn mind you're out of your
you're out of your [__] mind if you
think you're going to be passing laws in
states where you're going to take away
parents consent to to to do a non-med
check from a non-med professional of
children's
genitalia because they got to take a
[__] are you kidding me listen there is
a lot of classrooms all across this
state and all across the country but in
this state specifically where this
[__] [__] who doesn't know [__]
about his bill because he's a [__]
bonehead because he didn't write the
bill he didn't write some [__]
bigoted ass group like moms for liberty
or some [__] other
cousin [__] fascist group wrote this
[__] bill for this guy to sponsor
that's why he doesn't know [__] about it
he didn't know a [__] thing about
it not a goddamn thing and he ain't it
ain't designed for him to know a goddamn
thing but there's a lot of classrooms in
this state where this [__] [__] box
is trying to sponsor this [__] bill
where they would molest make it legal
for people to molest children in schools
because they got to go
piss
there's a lot of bathrooms in these
classrooms that are that have one
bathroom in the classroom and all the
genders all of them use the same [__]
bathroom it's the same it's the same
[__] it's one bathroom inside the
classroom the boys use it the girls use
it the teacher uses it they all use the
same
[__] this isn't about the [__]
bathroom it isn't it isn't about what
gender a child is
is it's about taking away the parents
[__] consent I live in the state I
have kids in these [__] schools this
[__] wants to take my consent
away from
me of having some non-medical
professional giving my child a
non-medical check
procedure because they don't know what
genitals they have to go into the
bathroom get the [__] out of here with
this fascist ass Nazi [__] you
[__] and especially when you
don't know what the [__] your bill says
um so are you familiar with the bosck
case Supreme Court case BOS versus
Clinton County I'm not no he's not of
course he's not so someone that was
assigned female at Birth in another
state yeah and then got their birth
cerificate change to mail comes to
Missouri and uses the men's restroom
under your
bill
supposedly if I'm in there and then
somebody who is authorized to use their
bathroom because of
their gender identity is in there don't
would could they possibly be arrested or
how does that
work another student is in there and
then the middle schooler goes into the
faculty bathroom not knowing that that
student is in there have they just
violated a law under your
bill you seek to Define sex in this bill
are you a doctor I'm not a doctor you
are not a doctor are you a biologist I'm
not a biologist are you a scientist of
any [__] nuggets I am not a scientist do
you know what the differences are
between primary sex and secondary sex
characteristics sure what are they can
you explain that to me and of course he
can't no he can't
you know primary sex characteristics you
know biological features
secondary probably you know emotional
you know basically anything that I would
consider not you know I guess primary
like visual
biological the doctor behind you is
shaking his head
no he doesn't know he doesn't know cuz
he didn't write the bill and they are
they're a bunch of Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets this is MAA this is all white
Christian nationalism by the way it's
all white Christian nationalism this is
where it stems from I keep telling you
Trump is not the threat he is a symptom
of the [__] disease that is rotting
the minds of our [__]
country this person has no he's elected
he's [__] elected he's a [__]
elected
official this guy
is a godamn representative in the state
of Missouri he is sent every single year
to the state of Missouri to session to
pass laws for his
constituents he [__] introduces a
bill where it makes it legal for
administrators and [__] faculty
members to feel up little children in
schools without the parents' consent
because they feel uncomfortable about
their
genitalia molesting they want to molest
kids they want to [__] their cousins
they want to elect a guy who got
syphilis from his [__] attorney I
don't know if Alena habba gave it to him
that's just my [__] guess that's my
guess I'm just
guessing Melania didn't definitely
didn't give it to him [__] she hadn't
been close enough to Milani hadn't been
close enough to [__] Trump to give
him syphilis
anyways
they're coming for your rights they're
coming for them and they don't give a
[__] how they got to get them and it
ain't just the [__] people who are
elected it's the people who control
their [__]
pockets it's the Haron
Hitlers it's the cat
Brothers It's the Herzog Foundation that
we talked about on Monday cuz the
voucher scheme the voucher scam in
schools you think the voucher scam is
about
schools no it's about taking away your
right as a [__] citizen of the state
that you're in for your kid to receive
an
education they want to take away your
[__] Liberty and they will chip away
at it and chip away at it and chip away
at it and chip away at it and they'll
use
things like roie Wade they'll use things
like the border the Border The Border's
the problem Oh The Border them brown
people coming here they'll use the fear
trans people chicks with dicks chicks
with dicks there's chick with dicks
everywhere they'll use the
fear to get elected and they'll use the
fear to take away your [__]
Liberty cuz they're white Christian
nationalist they're Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets that's why we get called well
you're Christian nationalist you want
you want the kingdom to be the
government
yes you want God to come and overtake
the government yes you want Christians
to be the only ones that yes we
do we wouldn't be a disciple of Jesus if
we didn't believe that you you want to
inspect children's genitalia in
elementary schools yeah you want to [__]
your cousins in Kentucky you want to
[__] your first cousins
yeah you want to make sure to ban
women's privacy in a doctor's office
yeah we're white Christian nationalists
we want to do all those things we want
to take away women's right to vote even
we don't want Taylor Swift to register
women to vote because we don't want
women to vote because how are we going
to take away their
rights if they can vote
yeah we're white Christian
nationalist we want God to be in control
of
everything we want Believers to be the
ones writing the laws yes guilty is
charged here you
go Christians
everywhere and you think Donald Trump's
the
threat that's it you're
thinking
you think Donald Trump's the one that is
is the big threat here [__] he's going
to be easy to
beat he's going to be [__] easy to
beat white Christian
nationalism that's the thing we need to
focus on and really honestly if Donald
Trump their lord and savior is at the
top of the
ticket and we can get America to turn
out against those [__]
against these white Christian
nationalists these Cheeto humping [__]
nuggets CU all he is is just their
[__] cult
leader it's all he is just their [__]
cult
leader but if we can get the turnout
high enough because the top of the
ticket has that [__] on
it then we can win these down bout
races we sure as hell can win back the
[__] house we sure as hell can sink
the Senate maybe you get close to 60
hell who [__]
knows with Ted with [__] boxes like Ted
Cruz and Josh Holly on those
tickets and I think we just might be
able to make that
happen that's why they want to stoke all
these culture wars that's why they
that's why they
continue to write these bills in these
states where they're trying to take away
your Schools they're trying to take more
women's rights and women's rights to
healthcare they're trying to chip away
at your parental consent for your
children to get [__] their genital
check to take a
[__] these children just want to go to
the [__]
bathroom and they're trying to make it
legal to where they can feel them up to
see because they're just not
sure they're just not
sure
I'm telling you there is a disease in
this
country and Trump is not the
disease he's just the wart that grows on
your ass because you've got that nasty
ass
disease that's what Trump is he's the
wart on your ass he's those sores on
your hands because you've contracted
syphilis
but white Christian nationalism is the
[__] problem it is the
disease speaking of Donnie and
civilis I found a new song by Tennessee
Brando my buddy Tennessee Brando oh my
God this is so good you guys are gonna
love this let's listen to downwind of
Donnie well I haven't written a song in
quite a while I've been kind of slacking
but I got the inspiration for this one
after watching a James Carville video I
call this downwind to
Donnie down with Donnie there's a hell
of a stench smelling like ketchup and
rotten
armpits
diaper there's
hell he CLS to we in
[Music]
at's the biggest that we ever have seen
he says he's a perfect specimen he never
gets sick
it's been 20 years and he still ain't
seen his dick where is it
down there's a hill of stench smelling
like ketchup and rotten armpits from the
sound of his diaper he sh down there's a
hell
ofch get down
[Music]
Donnie oh Tennessee Brando one of my
favorites there's Tennessee Brando and
you stick around we're going to do more
mocking and making fun of these [__]
it's boneh head of the week don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this have some
pizza we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast are you ready for best pizza of
life
bring friends down to pepperoni hug
spot our chefs make pizza with heart and
Special Touch cheese pepperoni vegetable
and more secret things need delivery
pizzas come fast knock knock who's there
pizza magic eat pepperoni hugs spot
Pizza your tummy say thank you your
mouth say m pepperoni hug spot it's like
family but with more
cheese catch Tony's twitch stream the
[__] list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast the [__] fam it's like family
but with
cheese pepperonis like a big pepperoni
hug spot you know what I
mean I don't know if that commercial
makes you want pizza or not but it does
me it makes me [__] want
makes me want pizza even though it's
kind of weird and funny and it's got all
the AI in it you know what I mean but
uh speaking of griffs what would this
show be without a proper grip that's
right we're gonna we're sponsored today
by super grip gummies super grip gummies
don't do [__] for you they absolutely
give you no vitamins no minerals they
taste like [__] they don't taste like
anything but you know just like a like a
gummy bear I guess a gummy bear
they don't make you healthier they don't
make you skinnier they don't make you
look better they don't make you look
younger they're really worthless but go
go to supergrip gums. gri supergrip
gums. gri now we want to grift you we
want your money we want your money you
want gummies you want to think you're
being healthy that's what a Griff's all
about so go to supergrip
what do you are you guys tired of that
one you want to go back to lawn juice
1000 lawn juice 1000 lawn juice 1000
tastes like [__] it tastes great it'll
even give you a third hand to hold the
jug give a thumbs up and hold a compost
shake it tastes like compost they it
tastes like your grandpa's compost pile
it really does tastes like [__] lawn
juice
1000 I can't believe some of these
people Haw this [__] you know what I
mean now there was I want to thank Tracy
uh Tracy Tracy put one in Discord
yesterday um and it's a it's called what
the hell is it
called I don't want to get it wrong it's
called like um explicit Essentials I
think it's what it's called yeah
explicit Essentials here I got it here
and they sell all kinds of like body
lotion and stuff like that um so we're
we've reached out to them so thank you
Tracy for bringing up and if you guys
actually do find a sponsor where you
like the product um you think the brand
would fit well with the Tony Michaels
podcast now you have to remember is they
can't be scared of me saying crazy [__]
so you got you gotta keep that in
mind but if you like the product we I I
want you guys to have good product the
one we're looking for is coffee now
we're working on getting a coffee for
you guys that you know because I think a
lot of people drink coffee it's a good
product if we can get a really good
tasting coffee and you find a coffee
that you like then I I think you might
you might you know go to that sponsor
but I don't want to I don't want to sell
you packets of green [__] that you put
in your water or sell you gummies that
don't do [__] for you okay I just I just
don't want to sell overpriced overpriced
compost shakes and
overpriced gummy bears yeah not gonna do
that so what we are going to Griff
though is we'll Griff the patreon page
so go to the Tony michaels.com pan on
down of memberships you can join the
patreon for free but you can also become
a member i' I've watched this we thank
you for everyone who's joined to be a
member some people have done it annually
if you pay your membership annually on
patreon if you decide to get in on the
Griff to keep this microphone powered on
against fascism because it is you that
keeps this microphone powered on against
fascism the audience uh then you if you
get 10% off if you do your uh your
membership there annually a free way to
support the show is link your Amazon
Prime account with your Twitch account
and I'll ask everyone last month we had
a ton of people hundreds of people who
linked their Prime account to their to
their Twitch account and they gave the
Tony Michaels podcast that one free
subscription you get with it you got to
go renew it even though you did it last
month you got to renew it for me to get
the Amazon money it doesn't cost you a
single thing but if you go to the Tony
michaels.com all the directions are
right there on that link all you got to
do is Click link Amazon and twitch the
directions to link it and the directions
to resubscribe it right there also you
should join the book club that's free
that's free for you to join too um the
the grip that I'm really excited about
I'm telling you this is the big one oh
my God I can't wait I got my t-shirt on
today and that's the the logo here let
me show you now here's the uh the logo
this machine kills fascist with the
microphone that's that that is going to
Inspiration Go on my arm on a tattoo and
I'm going to be live streaming it next
Friday next Friday the 26th so I want to
thank everyone again who has contributed
to the team tattoo fund now the team
tattoo fund all the money that goes in
there will go to the artist it will go
to the artist so and I think there's
like again if there's um if there's like
there's like I don't know if there's
like 20 people to give 20 bucks or 15
people to give $25 will reach our goal
and then all that money goes to the
artist and and he's getting a hoodie I
don't know if he's listening I hope not
um but he's gonna get a hoodie too I
bought the hoodie I got the hoodie and
my shirt in yesterday so I'm super
excited about that uh I'm really excited
now Dedra um Dedra I just got my tattoo
merch in the mail yay yeah it's it's
great it's real high quality it's heavy
the hoodie that I got uh it's the
premium hoodie with this logo on the
front and then this logo on the back if
you go to the Tony michaels.com you can
pen on down to the tattoo merch
collection and you get it there here let
me show you real quick um here's here's
what it looks like when you go to the
website this is here's the t-shirt that
I got this one right here the tattoo uh
fitted short sleeve t-shirt that's the
one that I got on right here um it's the
one with the logo on the front and the
the other one on the back and then the
hoodie I got I believe it
is believe it's this one right here and
I got the black one and it's really
heavy duty really warm super soft um
they're they're high quality stuff
that's why I picked this stuff out in
this store so it was high quality when
you guys get this stuff um and there's
there's a lot of other stuff in there
too you can get a long sleeve tea you
can get a coffee mug um there's uh
there's the stick
you put on your laptop you put it
anywhere really there's women's shirts
in there as well um coasters bags
there's uh posters there's tens there's
so much I got I actually got my wife one
of these crop hoodies and she really
likes it um if anyone's out there into
the crop hoodie so there's plenty of
stuff to pick from I'm super excited
about the tattoo I'm super excited that
you guys are excited about it uh so many
people reached out and said that they
wanted to they wanted to live stream
they wanted to watch it they were
willing to do something extra they
needed to so what you can do if you want
to watch the live stream of it go to the
tony.com click the team tattoo fund
stick in a dollar $2 $10 whatever you
got stick it in there and we'll get to
it and Dedra I can't wait to see a
picture of you with your merch so if you
want you can send me pictures with you
with your merch send it on Discord I'll
try to uh see that and if you want to
post it on social media and tag me if
you want like a retweet or something
I'll do that as well just try to tag me
you might have to do it a couple times
my my mentions and stuff
are sometimes kind of crazy they get
kind of crazy I try to read everything
Instagram is like the worst place to
message me I know some people message me
on Instagram that's like the worst place
Instagram DMS are just [__]
ridiculous like they're
crazy because they put them all on one
list like it it's just it's kind of
[__] nuts um on the
Instagrams the DMS so don't don't DM me
there unless you want me to see it like
a month from now because that's usually
what I do on Instagram I go in like once
a month and I just go through all the
DMS and it take it takes me sometimes
like an
hour to funnel through DMs that's how
crazy Instagram
is it's like an hour it takes me that's
why like some people are like oh Tony
doesn't respond to my
messages it's not that I don't want to
you know respond to your message it's
just that there's so [__]
many messages there's so there's so many
of them um so if you get frustrated that
I haven't answered your DM yet just hang
in there especially if it's if it's on
Instagram but that's the worst place to
DM me best place is probably Discord or
just tag me in Discord or talk to
someone like one of the mods that can
get a hold of me if you're really
looking U Facebook Messenger I know a
lot of you message me on Facebook
messenger and I try to get to those as
well but it's kind of the same way as
Instagram I I take a little bit of time
out of some some days just to go through
DMs over there um and it takes a little
bit to go through those DMS as well so
don't be afraid to DM me don't be afraid
to say stuff to me and if I don't
respond to you right away don't think
I'm just ignoring you and if I don't
respond to you it's not that I'm not
reading your message probably it's just
that I'm reading all kinds of other
messages so I'm trying
to trying to get it going all right all
right we're gonna have Gabe Sanchez on
here in just a minute I'm getting the
bonehead of the week ass it'ss Bon head
of the week super excited to have the
guy with the last name Sanchez back with
us here on the show uh let's see if we
can find something in the meantime I
want to show you a picture here is the
um oh [__] I got to show you Liam n Sons
uh analysis of this meanwhile in white
Manan Kentucky Republican introduces a
bill to legalized sex with the first
cousin and this is a report this is a
real thing this is Nick Wilson he was on
Survivor he was on
Survivor I I I
know he was on Survivor I don't I don't
know why that makes it qualified to
being a republican Congressman but this
doesn't this guy look like a cousin
[__] fascist you know what I mean I
mean I don't know to me kind of kind of
with the [__] the weird ass smile the
fake
smile I like to [__] my
cousin her name is
[Music]
Cheryl I don't know this isn't Arkansas
it's Kentucky which is kind of
surprising I mean I guess you know maybe
it shouldn't be a surprise because
I I think I think down in Arkansas it's
legal to [__] your
cousin um Brooke Brook says he won a
million dollars so he actually he won
Survivor this guy wasn't just on
Survivor this guy [__] won Survivor
you know what I mean he [__] won
Survivor and he wants to [__] his cousin
I don't know if winning Survivor winning
a million bucks makes you want to [__]
your cousin but it makes me not want to
play the lottery I don't know let's see
if the guy with the last name Sanchez
have you ever [__] your
cousin oh
God Tony Tony Tony no no I have not I'll
answer that no I have not you can Hey
listen if you want to it's all right
there's Arkansas and then now Kentucky
ky's trying to make it yeah but we can't
remember I mean we can't remember we
cannot forget yeah a very important
person who is a cousin [__] well hang
hang on hang on I didn't forget I didn't
forget we did this in the in the
producers scner this morning here is the
um here's the here's here's
the here's the
um here's the thumbnail from today
cousin cousin [__] you know what I
mean it's uh look it's verifiable it's a
fact the guy married his second cousin
which one which one of these you gotta
you gotta you gotta clear this up
because because Trump wants to [__] his
daughter okay Rudy has [__] his cousin
Rudy Giuliani his his first wife was his
second cousin MH and it's almost like
they're like nobody's going to find this
one out you know oh but the guy with the
last name Sanchez has verified it how
did you how did we verify how can you
verify that how do you do you go to like
State records do you find out who they
were born to and like I don't know how
they I honestly don't know how they came
up with or how they discovered that one
like it might have been but I mean like
how would you know unless well well I
mean you could say that l you could say
it out loud like Donald Trump's like
yeah if I Vanka wasn't my daughter I'd
be [__] her yeah I mean you could
have that just like a tape because they
didn't have the same last name so what I
imagine happened was somebody was like
wait hold on you guys are getting
married but you're at the same family
functions every year right you're at the
family reunions and then somebody
probably came forward and was like hey
just so you guys
know they cousins it's really strange
your camera's blurry what's the hell's
going on with it all right give me one
second feels like it is no no don't go
anywhere don't go anywhere just just
change it we want to see it in real time
how how it changes
yeah oh hold no I gotta I gotta I gotta
no no no no you no no
no he's gonna go on come again I I want
you guys to see him in full 4K okay he's
got to be clear it's got to be it's got
to be pristine for the guy with the last
name Sanchez he's not here enough um so
we're excited to have him on Fridays for
Bon head of the week so I want it to be
crystal clear that you see the beautiful
face of the guy with the last name
Sanchez um but while he's doing that uh
let's switch to let's do this let's go
to a break when we come back we have
bone into of the week don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only $50 a day
you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror the these are those
Trump supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another moment [__]
them [__] [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast all right I think we got the
camera issues fit maybe maybe we'll see
we got it cleared up you can see the
beautiful face clearly yeah I fixed it I
fixing you I fixed it I [__] fixed it
bro it's Friday you know what that means
guy with the last name Sanchez and head
of the week oh look at that it's already
up there not [__] look at that there we
go look at that look look at these two
Bone Heads talking about a few bone bone
heads B how are you Mr Sanchez hey man
good I I just can't can't complain right
now you know how's that card treating
you you still it's still R it's good
good I drove it last night it was nice
oh I went to I went to rehearsal are you
liking it better than your than your car
that got stolen yeah this one has seat
warmers and has
a you live in Los Angeles [__]
what the [__] do you know I mean you're
from Chicago so you know I'll give you
that you know what cold is and you went
to college in Wisconsin I I I I get
that look look look look your body
changes okay man when you move to
different climates your body changes and
I can tell you [__] Coastal these
Coastal LST with their their body
changing temper got this i got this baby
skin okay as soon as I moved as soon as
I moved from Chicago to San Francisco
yeah within a year and a half a year and
a half 18 my body had already been like
oh okay my new I was like my new normal
is like 65 new normal and then I moved
to LA where it was much warmer yeah
and it's did it take 18 months for you
to acclimate to being cold at 65 degrees
or I mean yeah and then when I you got
to have your [__] wa okay now I got I
gotta I gotta ask you this when do you
turn on in Los Angeles when is the
temperature too low that you got to turn
on your [__] seat warmer even if it's
on
low uh what was last night last night
was in the last night was like 40 50
something like that but I got in the car
and was freezing so I had to and I
didn't have a I didn't have a hoodie
with me I didn't have my jacket or my
hoodie with me yeah because it's 55° you
don't need a goddamn you don't need a
coat when it's
55° when I got in the car it was cold
dude and I had to drive earlier this I
was like gotta get this butt on earlier
this week I got in my truck to go get my
coffee and go on my walk and my truck is
parked in the garage now I have seat
warmers in my truck and they are nice
they heat your cheeks yeah I never had
them before they were great right
they're they're it's [__] awesome now
on my dashboard it was negative two okay
I don't want to hear your [__] about
turning on your seat warmer when it's
[__] 55 degrees outside it was
negative two Okay negative not two
degrees I'm just saying these these
cheeks were a little cold and they
needed a little bit of a love okay you
know oh so I turn them on you know I
turn I didn't I didn't have on the whole
ride it was you know like 20 minute
drive and I turned him on and I got 10
minutes in I was like okay now we're
toasty and I I turned it off and I was
like I'll just have the residual kind of
warmth going on uh you know it also
didn't help I got in the car and the AC
was already going because I need the AC
the other day it's just you know all
over the place my [__] god during the
day it's hot at night it's cold it's
crazy oh my [__] go you gotta be
kidding me one day you need the AC and
the next day you need the heated seat
wait wait wait wait do you run the AC
and the heated seat all at the same time
no is that I'm not a serial killer
what you what am I some kind of [__]
monster speaking of monsters let's get
to bone of week cuz we got some monsters
on this list monster boneheads and just
some complete monsters Matt gats Donald
Trump Donald Jessica Trump Grandpa
syphilis or as you might know him
Grandpa Hitler and then Mike Ro Johnson
the wiener of the
house boy I don't know it feels like to
me that that micro Johnson's in a lot of
trouble here I feel like a lot of people
are like oh no no he's going to be cool
but I'm like you know what Kevin
McCarthy wasn't cool hey man we look we
called it from the first day he got in
we said he has he's between a rock and a
hard place right he's either go a or
civilist and cousin [__] whatever you
know whatever you hey whatever you're
fancy okay call right-handed um but what
I will say is that from the very
beginning it was the the guy was in a
difficult position he was either he had
to go crazy mag extreme and not get
anything done and then have the
constituents look and say well you guys
had the you had the you had the control
of the house and you took away someone
because they were a you know they worked
with Biden on a on a budget resolution
and they work with uh Schumer so we're
going to remove you so now we're gonna
get someone who's even more Maga I mean
you had Matt Gates telling Steve ban at
one point it was like [__] glory be
to God we have someone who is going to
be the direct messenger of the man
himself the guy called himself that he
said I it was it was God's choice that I
became Speaker of the House well Steve
speaking of civilist speaking of
civilist uh Steve Bannon and Matt gats
are now speaking against him here's
here's here's here's Mr cilis himself
this aged all too well yeah let's watch
they're gonna Jam in a
CR this is shows you the
irresponsibility if Johnson pulls these
tricks hey our our thing is get rid of
him go you you're not the man for the
moment bye say Steve you can't say they
just got in no no a leader will emerge
that's what happens in these turnings
leaders
emerge leaders like Trump like he's a
great leader now here's the thing is
that all this [__] with the shut
down of the government and the Border
stuff and oh we want to we want to
secure the Border but we don't want
Biden to win if we actually secure the
Border or some [__] yeah we won't take
the money the resources the extra
funding and people no no no no we we
can't take that which is a direct uh a
direct response from Biden to say you
guys have complaints about the Border
Great here is me helping you we won't
take the technology we won't take the
Manpower we won't take the
funding okay well if you don't take it
then how are you going to make it better
if you say if you say right now there's
a problem and you're unwilling to take
the help that I'm offering
then what are we doing and then it's
like oh well of course it's it's Joe
Biden Joe Biden's a Democrat we can't
give Joe Biden a win because that's
going to help him going into the 20
election well the other thing it hurts
is they can't campaign on that now yeah
they can't c campaign on the border and
blood poisoning if they fixed it they
can't campaign on it now here here's the
thing and I and I know this issue is
deeply rooted uh with your family
because your father comes from Mexico he
he actually came here and he made a life
for himself that's why you're here your
mom your brother your family and you
have family down here family up there
that's that's why the guy with the last
name Sanchez is even right here on the
show in the first place that's true but
yesterday um because I got sick and
tired of hearing even Democrats saying
even even like Eric Schall was saying
fix the problem fix the problem it
listen the border the imaginary line is
not a [__] problem it is not a
problem for people to come in this
country and to become American it was
not a problem when your dad came to this
country
to become American to raise a family to
have a great son with the guy with the
last name San to be on this show every
Friday and do Bon the week and mock
these [__] idiots there's not
problems with it now there are problems
that arise when when large amounts of
migrants come to this country there are
those problems one of the problems is
the Republican party doesn't want to
make sure that we welcome them with open
arms and that we don't do a damn good
job as a country making sure that we
find these people where they need to go
in the country to assimilate whether
it's to find jobs or be close to their
families or be close to communities who
need these migrants there are
communities that absolutely 100% need
these migrants they need them they need
them rather they're refugees they're
undocumented they're documented it
doesn't matter the this country needs
these folks to become American and to
stay here it is actually it is actually
not in our best interest sometimes for
migrant workers to come here and go back
we want them [__] stay here and be
part of our communities that is how we
[__] grow our economy that's how we
become a strong country that's how we
become more diverse that is how it works
you know what really pisses me off and
and I know this is close in home to you
too um I I have a lot of people that I
know who who are like The Border's
problem the border border border all
these illegals coming into the country
and then they'll go to the the Mexican
restaurant and they [__] love eating
oh man but even beyond that it's not
even just the Mexican restaurant if you
look at the back of the house right you
look at the kitchen yep and you'll find
a sushi restaurant an Italian restaurant
you know whatever it is you're always
who's doing that back there who's doing
that back you might find someone that is
like oh yes I'm authentic to that
culture and that region whatever but
you're GNA find Mexicans
Guatemalans uh Cubans whoever it might
be like you're going to find people from
the Latino Community who are there
working trying to find are trying to you
know steing that job that those white
people want right Wasing dishes
scrubbing the pants that's the biggest
and that's my biggest biggest biggest
biggest complaint is when I hear a
[__] Karen or Kevin say oh they're
stealing our jobs okay so let me let me
just understand you were going to go to
that field and you were going to pick
that head of lettuce you were G to pick
those strawberries you were going to go
to the back of the kitchen you were
going to bust those tables you were
going to go do the the hourly minimum
wage or less than minimum wage job that
you say that these people are stealing
get the [__] out of here when I hear
that [__] it pisses me off because I
know and you know and I'm sure everyone
in the audience knows this is that when
people say they're stealing our jobs no
they're not because if they were
stealing our jobs then you I mean you
would have a legitimate case to make if
you were actually going for that job
Karen but you're not what you're doing
is you're bitching and moaning about a
problem that isn't actually a
problem that you think it is you're
creating an issue it's a republican
issue it's a problem that they are
projecting onto other people to say
they're the problem no the Republican
part's the problem in their lack of
Health Care lack of Education lack of
actually trying to improve the border so
it's not just put people in cages and
shoot people or catch them up and barb
wire in a river it's not that the
solution is to actually hold your
Christian values and say hey you know
what I will house you I will clean you I
will feed you I will take care of you
but Republicans don't want to ever do
that they just want to say uh you know
what shoot first ask questions later and
we're going to make sure that everyone
whoever whoever wanted to seek Asylum is
now going to be sent on a bus or a plane
to an area that isga -2 or -10 or
wherever like the people that are
sending uh Abbott Dan santis and whoever
is sending people to the east coast up
north New York who are sending people to
[__] Chicago are are it's vile it's
gross it's disgusting well
trying to create an image they're trying
to create an image of a problem that
doesn't have to exist because what we
can do as a country is we can welcome
these people with open arms because you
know this better than I will because my
my generation of of my family who came
here who came here not for the
betterment of them but for the
betterment of their children and their
grandchildren you probably see that time
and time again the people in the fields
picking strawberries and the head of
lettuce and washing the pans they don't
come here to get rich from washing pans
and the the back of a restaurant they
don't come here to get rich to pick
strawberries they come here so their
children have an opportunity so their
grandchildren have an opportunity just
like just like you have experienced
because your dad came here to give you
and your brother and your family an
opportunity and I just I can't I I mean
yeah are sure are there people with bad
intent coming across the border sure
yeah absolutely but where isn't there
anywhere in the way of life or society
that there's not someone with bad intent
and that we don't have law to prevent
those people from doing the stuff that's
bad intend it's illegal to traffic drugs
it's illegal it's already illegal it's
already illegal when someone's
trafficking drugs you can prosecute them
that's what you can do yeah you can do
that but we should make it easy and we
should welcome people here to walk
across an imaginary line or fly across
an imaginary line it doesn't matter
where it's at it doesn't matter who it
is if they want to be and that right
there is the biggest when and for people
in the audience whenever someone's like
oh you know these migrants no no no no
the people that are that come here
illegally are the ones who come on Visa
who overstay their welcome who don't
intend to go back to their country until
the point at which they're deported
because they get caught by some
agency those are the people there's
actually a large amount of people who
fly who come in
Legally and then overstay their welcome
because they decided not to go back and
just come from
come from the north yeah how many how
many I don't know how many and I know we
got a lot of Canadians in the honest I
don't know how many Canadians come to
America and just stay here a lot of them
go to La there's a lot of them that go
to La and and Pamela Anderson was here
undocumented for a long time I I watched
the pamel Anderson um the documentary I
I think it's called Pam or Pamela it's
on Netflix it's a pretty good
documentary but she talks about how she
came to LA and she had a tough time
getting into the United States because
you you just can't just get into the
United States like and she was just
trying to get here so that she could go
to the Playboy Mansion like that was her
goal and then when she got here they she
couldn't do a lot of things because she
wasn't here legally she was just here to
go to the Playboy mansion and have a few
pictures taken and look at the
contribution that Pam Anderson gave us I
mean and I can tell you the other thing
too is some you were talking about is
like you know people who were coming to
this country and they you know they're
they're not trying to get rich washing
pants I know from experience like when
my dad came here one of the big things
and he still did it from from a time or
till till he moved back to Mexico but he
would send money back to my family he
would send money to my abolita he would
send money to my tias he would send
money to my my Primos and it's like the
idea that someone is like oh they're
coming here to uh to do crazy insane
crimes or they're coming here to get
rich off the backs of us for the jobs
that we were never willing to
do these people and again I speak from
experience my dad came here and would
send money back to my family in Mexico
on a regular basis that was just part of
the thing he was like great I'm making
more money here than I would in Mexico
and I'm creating more opportunities here
and I'm starting a family and I'm going
to send money back and contribute back
to my family who helped get me to where
I am it's insane it's crazy that that's
and and this is um you know because we
talked about this on the show before how
as as part of the Hispanic population in
this country has turned to Maga and it's
not surprising to me and I know it's not
really surprising to you because the
Hispanic Community is deeply rooted in
their fate and they're deeply rooted in
family and family values so when someone
gives them horseshit about family values
like the Republican Party does sometimes
they bite and they fall for that
nonsense and again it's not nonsense in
that the family value shouldn't be there
it's nonsense that Republican actually
think that there should be good Family
Values is just a way to attract someone
to vote for them yeah um you know and
that's that's the way it is kind of like
um Mike RH Johnson here you know keeps
his family on check with the porn they
watch speaking of porn and speaking of
showing porn to people on the house
floor there's Matt gats did you know
Mark way Moen has said that Matt Gat
showed underage porn to other
Representatives on the house for did you
know that I'm not saying that Mark yeah
no I know he yeah he told CNN that and I
think my biggest takea away from that
moment when when everything was falling
to [__] the first time through with uh
with Kevin McCarthy my biggest takeaway
was so you witnessed that and you said
nothing you didn't do anything right
keep in mind that you know you're while
you saw this on the house floor like as
a representative you saw this because
now you're a senator you a
representative you were on the house
floor and you saw this and you said yeah
it's all right it's just it's just it's
it's beas or is he but is he under girls
uh he's oh [__] what is he is he beus or
butthead I I don't
know cool cool yeah
Co I am kol I for my M um you know no
one's familiar with beus and Butthead um
but he does he does look like beas and
Butthead [__] had a baby but but but
but you know what the funny part about
this is is because we were talking about
immigration we were talking about
demonizing Hispanic people right and
then you were talking about Karen's he
does all this in one clip basically
saying we don't want women to vote for
Republicans listen what I could tell you
is like for every Karen we lose there's
a there's a Julio and a Jamal ready to
sign up for the Maga movement and that
abodes well for our ability to be more
diverse and to be more durable as we
head into what I more diverse we want we
want brown and black men we don't want
women wait wait wait wait Tony Tony I
thought this was the party of anti- Dei
wasn't this the party of we don't need
div they can't make up their minds are
you kidding me this is my
you you you act like they put thought
into these things and future proof this
you know they don't future proof Gabe
Sanchez that's true I know I know they
don't future prooof I know they don't
ever think uh further than five minutes
ahead of because I mean that's what they
do right they make a claim they get some
15 seconds of like Limelight on some
interview on some show like Newsmax
because that's super credible um and
then you find that they end up eating
their own words an hour later or
whatever it might be I mean just look at
James comr James comr was just caught by
Hunter Biden's was it Hunter Biden's
lawyer Hunter no the witness's lawyer
just caught comr and a lie and now it's
been revealed that they want the full
tapes the full deposition or testimony
to be revealed because the lawyer was
like wait wait none of the stuff that my
witness said is what you guys claim that
he said Oh you mean you mean Republicans
are liars this is it's crazy crazy I I
we we need to retract a statement here
apparently digital waterfall is a little
uh insulted it's an insult to be and
buad to compare to compare this guy to
be and buad I I completely agree I don't
usually your track statements but I'll
will retract all right I will retract
that fine
fine oh but there's so many things why
this guy is uh is a boneh head and a
butt head but I will say
that it is kind of telling because with
all this Taylor Swift talk like they're
terrified to her man they are [__]
it's crazy to see how how obsessed they
are and you have to remember the things
they are most obsessed with are the
things that they fear right they're OB
genitalia yeah no they love it they they
they love it I just did a video uh
that's on my on my channel for what was
that and it was about Donald Trump Trump
he he's he has started and I've tracked
all the other states that he's made
videos for he's made videos for the
caucuses the primaries to say like hey
you don't know how to register make sure
to go to this place make sure to go here
here's a you know stem statement from a
lawyer blah BL and then they have this
genderless neutral [__] Ikea uh
creature right have you you ever done
the iea manual no oh well in okay for
people who have in the Ikea manual
there's like this like I've been to an
Ikea okay all right who knows maybe you
wanted some meatballs and you decided to
go to IKEA who knows it could be but in
the Ikea manual there's like this
genderless creature that's like watch me
put together this thing I've got a
hammer you know that type of [__] and
how how' that go again it goes It goes
like this watch me put together this
[__] I've got a
hammer so
you you see this video and it's just
it's just like like no genitalia no
gender right the guy's name is or I
guess he's a gender or whatever but his
name is Marlin but he's completely naked
and then in every other shot in in the
in the video you see the other
characters and they're all
also genitalia free so they're just like
just a just a a bean they're just a
bean're they're not they're not a man
they're not a woman they're just a
regular be and they're Bean on a woman
most guys don't know that but in there
Bean on yeah that's true I don't think I
don't think Republicans are like beans I
hate beans and rice that's what they
would probably say oh okay I get because
that's how much they love the you know
Latino Community apparently they go to
the restaurant this bone head has
responded um just just recently oh of
course stat of course so let's watch him
say more bone headed step before before
we move on to the dishonorable mention
safe to say that based off of your
comments you're suggesting that these
women at these abortion rallies are ugly
and overweight yes oh what do you say oh
wait this is an old one this is an old
one that's the one that's the one that's
like oh yeah he's an [__] he hates
women not only that not only that which
is crazy because if you think about what
Donald Trump said he was like oh we need
the Suburban women we need the PE we
need those women but I'm pretty sure
that you're gonna have those Karens in
there wait no this is new wait a second
let's see let's see anything
people who think that those comments are
offensive be offended what I could tell
you is like for every Karen we lose
there's a there's a Julio and a Jamal
ready to sign up for the magum movement
and that abots well for our there is
there was another clip yeah there was
another clip from 2022 I think maybe
like summer 2022 where he
said um that was the one where they they
eat their wine their they have their
wine and their TV dinner and they have
their cats remember that statement yeah
I think I remember that that was the one
where he went after them and was like oh
yeah well I don't really care about
these women who go home and eat alone
with their TV dinner and their glass of
wine and their 50 cats or whatever it
was it was something along those lines
he and almost forbade him but very close
he made that statement in the summer of
2022 I think it was where he went after
women and it's like oh man way to way to
be way to be a good man way to be a
great man so a cat right like right yeah
yeah like
like like this like yeah do we know
that's that's for that's in fact him
well I mean I don't know does the
internet care I don't know I don't think
look look all I can say is does the
internet is the internet caring okay
just just want to say Matt Gates is
looking like a good tiger gonna
pounce okay many people are saying
excuse me excuse me many people are
saying that he's got a spider
dick
Matt Gat I also love the [__] Spy
Kids poster in the back
like I mean I mean the guys the guys
because he wants to spy on kids I get it
there we go there we go that's why
that's why rare rare rare rare all right
let's move on um to
another [__] eating represent quick
quickly quick quickly do you think that
for every Julio and Jamal there's also a
nester there could be probably I'm just
I'm just saying I don't know if it's
consensual but I think there's I think
for every one of them there's another
Nester you know what's funny on this
list two of the bone EDS this week have
their you know their Nester they really
do they have their Master but let's move
on to the DM another boneheaded
representative margorie Taylor pedetti
green oh my God there's so many
boneheaded things we can't put her on
bonehead of the week anymore yeah yeah
we can't do that we can give her we can
give her a DM or an AC but we can't give
her she's gonna win no matter what right
she's well she's only she's only lost
once in the poll that she's ever she's
she's only had one loss and then we
disqualified her from being on the polls
but now this year we we have to rename
it Marge Madness right Marge Madness
Marge Madness when we get she won last
year and that was the we said it the
first year I was like if she wins we'll
rename it Marge Madness and then the
next year she won well we were talking
about immigration earlier and she said
something um truly stupid airport one
huh is this the airport one no no this
is the the largest deportation operation
in history in our history which she
doesn't know that the actual largest
deportation operation history was under
Barack Obama like this is not the this
is not the flex you think it is when you
get down to the facts of who deported
the most people actually well I mean you
say facts and they don't know what that
means well that is true they are kind of
scared of them but here's here's Marge
because all they're like is like
deportation because they're like trains
gas Chambers and camping like that's
where their minds go not just like
making sure that people who are supposed
to be are here and people who aren't
supposed to be here you know speaking of
trains that reminds me of how Margie
Taylor green when the train uh
derailment happened in Palestine she
goes well train arals happen all the
time and it's like okay that should not
be the response that you have you should
not be like well
a thousand trains crash a year big deal
big deal people I mean not the approach
should elementary school children get
shot and killed by high power rifles
every day what's the big [__] deal I
mean guys calm down jeez but brown
people and wieners brown people and
wieners I want to know about that all
right let's hear let's hear talk about
Mass deportation looking forward to the
next Administration where we're going to
have the largest deportation system
that's ever
wit in human history because the
American people deserve to have a safe
country safe borders and I'll finish up
with this we will be impeaching
secretary mayorcas because he has broken
the laws and these are the laws that Joe
Biden himself put in place thank you Mr
chairman I yield I'm a lawmaker I'm in
Congress and I'm the one who makes the
laws but I don't even know that Joe
Biden is the one who doesn't make Joe
Biden didn't make laws Joe Biden make
laws did you see her um her back and
forth rather just like it wasn't really
back and forth but it was witness oh
yeah I'm going to show that one too and
she was like oh my God just Relentless
this is I mean this is the epitome of
Republican confirmation bias and Dunning
Krueger like the the two had a baby and
you come out with marar Taylor green
it's the idea it's the idea that she she
doesn't get the answer she wants but
it's not because the person is lying and
it's not because she has facts like it's
not like if you were a lawyer
cross-examining a witness to be like I
have proof that what you're saying is
perjury and you're ly and here is the
exam exhibit
ABC uh margorie Taylor green has this
idea of what she wants it to be she
wants it to be either mayor's fault or
Biden's policies and then when she
doesn't get the answer that she wants
she just continues to berate and
belittle the witness to a point where
she's like well I can answer this
question but you don't want that answer
because you already have an idea in your
mind so that's how you again that's how
you know that we're not dealing with
serious people marar Taylor green Lauren
bobbert Matt Gates uh Mike Johnson
Donald Trump Andy bigs uh Paul gosar
like all these people are not serious
people these are people and there's tons
of others as well but these are not
serious people these are people who take
their xenophobic bigoted regret
aggressive policies and
ideas and try to implement them into a
country right we say this is the
greatest country of all time you United
States is the greatest country but
they're actively trying to make it the
worst country which goes into the whole
Nicki Haley this is not a racist country
[__] but she's not on the list of
boneheads this week next I know she'll
be on next week next here's here here
She is
uh oh with the [__] cousin [__]
fascist word s let's listen if so then
maybe we shouldn't be having hearings on
my articles of impeachment to impeach
secretary mayorcas maybe we should be
holding articles of impeachment on the
president of the United States is that
where we're going what do you think
about do you think is it a policy
difference or is it this lady's like
what what what i is there a question
here that is relevant to I don't know
what you're the also Mar Taylor green
goes like she takes out the glass she's
like do we have to go with articles of
impeachment My article I don't want I
just want to know how many articles of
impeachment does margar Taylor green
have like how many has she brought
forward we know at least there's one or
two Joe Biden on depends on the peach
tree the impeach tree dish impeach tree
and which gapo or gacho police that
she's going to use right it it's just I
I look at this and I see Margie Taylor
green say like do we have to bring my
articles of impeachment you were waiting
for that opportunity to drop in that you
had articles of impeachment ready to go
against mayorcas like you you have a
template a boilerplate template file
that says it's a mad libs person thing
they did and the date and then you just
po you just post that in and then you're
like all right great we got one ready to
go for we got one ready to go for Harris
and we got one ready to go for Biden we
got one ready to go over Hunter Biden
even though he's not in an office we got
ready to go for may orcus we got ready
to one for Garland We got R blinkin like
all of these people you know what it
feels like you you know those you know
those Schoolboard meetings where those
people would come in and it felt like
they're reading off their Facebook page
that's what it feels like Marie Taylor
green is just sitting in she's an
elected official and she just like
scrolling down her her Facebook page
reading off memes really loudly into the
microphone secretary mayorcas which one
Biden Joe Biden or secretary
Marcus my impression of the allegations
that the majority has raised here is
that they are entirely about policy
differences with Miss pearlstein you've
talked about policy in your testimony
today policy so that would be Joe Biden
I'm sure you voted for him for president
you're you've been talking about the B
love for her to be like I actually voted
for Trump yeah no actually I voted for
the other guy the other [__] who
tried to overturn the government with
you who tried to take away my has been
the cause of all of this so is it Joe
Biden's policy the administration's
policy or is it secretary
mayoras by the way I don't know if
Marjorie uh knows this Marge the pett
yeti knows this but you can't impeach
someone based on policy disagreements
that's something whoa whoa whoa whoa you
can't do that you can't do I can't I
can't I can't say that I want to impeach
someone just because I don't like them
you also you also can't impeach someone
who is trying to negotiate US border
security with other legislators like in
the senate or something and then the
president's saying yeah I'll sign I'll
sign that bill and may is like yeah I
support that bill um and they're like no
you don't because we don't want you to
because then we can't sell your
impeachment legitimately the other thing
you can't do is you can't like lie about
witness testimony like comr it just kind
of totally undermines the whole
investigation in Hunter Biden
and getting Hunter Biden to actually
talk Hunter here he's here to answer
questions he's here to answer
questions he was it's it's it's
something that always gets Republicans
like their words always come back to
bite them in the ass they make some
complaint or they [__] and moan about
some issue and say it's not fair because
Democrats said this and they won't let
us do this or they won't interview or
they won't give a testimony or you won't
give us funding or you won't sign that
bill or whatever it is right just a
medley of excuses of why Democrats
aren't doing the job they should do
according to Republicans but as soon as
you said as soon as Republicans get what
they want and that being a Democrat says
great I'll give a testimony I will bring
the witness I will sign that bill I will
offer you funding and resources that you
ask for as soon as they get that thing
that fixes the problem that they are
campaigning on they have to go whoa okay
okay that's actually okay what I meant
was um I can't I can't have you actually
fix the problem and I can't let it be
Democrats that fix the problem because
if it is then we all look like idiots
who and and most likely are going to
have our constituents question why they
elected us because if we can't get the
job done if the government shuts down we
can't secure the Border we can't give
you funding we we can't forgive student
loans whatever it might be it begins to
a it begins to have their own
constituents say well wait hold on if
you didn't do those things and Democrats
tried to fix those things and you said
no then why do we why do we have you in
office why why why are you existing in
our government why do you keep taking
money and you just got a
pension speaking of people who can't do
their jobs this brings me to the alpha
cook now I don't know why you put him on
as the alpha cck I'm not really sure but
I'm hoping that you put rad damama
dingdong on as the alpha cck here I'm
hoping rad damama dingdong got on Alpha
cook uh for a certain moment that
happened uh this week at the Iowa caucus
it was cold they're running around um
and you know have any seed heaters but
whatever right they have to speak at
these events
and when V radama dingdong got to one of
these events he had to speak into a
kid's light up karaoke machine I'm not
kidding you want you think it was his
kid's karaoke machine I have no idea
whose karaoke machine is this this has
got to be a setup right they totally
[__] punked him on this someone yeah
we'll give you a big big huge oh big
huge microphon if
you be you just go down there they'll
give you the biggest it'll be the
greatest microphone ever you gotta okay
excuse me okay okay it can't be bigger
than mine okay but it's going to look
like a dick and I know dicks because I'm
a dick taster look okay B you're gonna
love it okay it's GNA be great many many
great people okay you speaking to a
microphone it's gonna light up be bam
boom it's gonna be awesome it's the idea
that that this guy who was relatively a
nobody right no one in politics knew him
nobody knew how to say his last name
nobody knows how to say his first no
it's it's rad damama dingdong I know I
know I've got a what was that on this
that goes through the more or less the
timeline and why this was all all to
plan right which is what we've talked
about how this is a the moment I heard
him speak I was like this guy's a plant
yeah this guy is he's a spoiler candid
he's a surrogate he's a proxy he's not
there to become president but he's there
to split the vote of
other uh Trump candidates of opponents
but he totally did this he totally
talked into a [__] kid's light up
Koke machine at one of these campaign
events oh this is the guy who runs
around with the truth hat and the truth
Banner falling on him like the truth is
falling on him and then he speaks into a
he was hit with the truth right over
like literally hit over the head with
the
truth oh my God and you could I mean
it's just like the the irony is great
right well that brings us to uh ramama
damama dingdong being the alpu this is
probably the last time you ever actually
see this
guy no I mean on the show yes unless he
does or says think he'll do something
relevant you think he'll do I honestly
think look at look at George Santos
everyone was like oh look he's now yeah
right right he's red do you know that
George Santos is dropping the prices of
his uh his cameos he's losing like
there's no popularity in the guy anymore
the last interview he did was with
Pierce Morgan he went back on the show a
year later just recently in the last
week he went on the show and Pierce
Morgan was like Pierce who's Pierce
Morgan who's this guy yeah yeah right
okay so a nobody interviewed another
nobody and they had a conversation and
the one the British nobody asked the who
knows what nobody uh about why he lied
and the the the drag queen nobody said
I don't know why I lied and then he was
like on the verge of tears he and then
the British nobody was like is it like a
mental health thing is it like uh you
have an issue you diagnosed with
something like do you have growing up
it's republicanism and and they you know
and and George Santos made the mistake
that he that he liked every Republican
line he liked all of them so he just
used all of them and tried to make it to
where he was all the lies and it didn't
work out for him cuz most Republicans
know you can only pick a few of the
lines you can only pick a few of them
unless unless unless you're the biggest
bonehead of all time like uh the
bonehead of the week this week Donald
Jessica Trump is the Bon head of the
week oh my God there's so many things
this week with this guy I mean
there's the judge Kaplan telling alen
Haba and him to shut the [__] down shut
up sit down and shut the [__] up shut up
and sit down you know and then Fox News
Fox News fact checked him this
morning what what did they what was the
fact check this morning the claim that
Donald Trump made last night or yeah
last night was that uh Democrats could
show up and and vote in this primary and
they were like independent scan no they
he made a claim about Democrats he said
Democrats could show up and then they
were like well no actually what it is is
you could be if you had
registered in October 6th I think it was
so nobody could just show up and be like
Oh I'm here to vote no you have to be
registered Republican or independent to
vote but the Democrat Democrats cannot
just show up on the primary and try to
off like just swing the votes one way
right in Missouri you can do that
Missouri has open primaries you can you
can do honestly what people should have
done uh was they should have changed
their registration
before October who were Democrats to
then because you know we're not having a
primary for Joe Biden we're not going to
be doing that so what we should have
done honestly is we should have changed
our votes or our registration to
Republican in these primary States and
then
voted for some other Third Party
candidate like someone else just [__]
write in someone else right Mickey Mouse
or whoever yeah there you go or maybe
even maybe even James Carville this is
one of the videos this week that kind of
went uh viral um speaking of viral
there's another one about a virus that
also went viral with James carel but
here I'll I'll show this one first we
have to communicate bck so let me give
you example you're looking at the
background all right I have three years
here one 1996 One
1999 one 2000 one 2003 it's a multiple
choice what is now Trump is fat okay
he's really fat he he's he's
real he's he is fat he is really fat
okay I have not I just want to say I
have not seen this clip so I'm watching
I have not seen this oh my God and now
I'm like oh I got I'm gonna have to
throw this into here listen listen
because it it gets better let me back it
up just a bit because it's good all
right choice what is now Trump is fat
okay he's really that F they put on his
physical weighs 230 PBS I tell I'll make
anybody this bet Trump you get on the
SCH scale and every pound under 230 I'll
pay you a th000 if every pound over 230
you pay me
$10 and I'm going to the bank so the
question is what is the last here you
think that Trump actually saw his
dick I don't think he seen it in
this the century really doesn't start
till January 1st 2001 weird thing but
I I give him the benefit of that that's
what that's how what a fat piece of [__]
I
think now there's there's another
part he's fat he's really fat when's the
last year Donald Trump seen his
dick oh my God I was not I didn't know
where this was going okay oh you didn't
oh oh no I didn't know I did not know it
was the year in which the last time that
Donald Trump's off dick oh man I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to use that clip for sure
wow that that one's fantastic now I've
got another Carville clip and then I've
got a song that was written about these
Carville clips that I showed earlier but
I want to show it to you too uh it's a
it's a friend of our Tennessee brander
road but here's another clip from
Carville um here he is I think I I think
oh no this is different CP I didn't see
this one all right he's getting medical
advice from doctors here about a c I did
see I saw part of this yes yes yes if
you go to the Drudge Report and I think
it'll still be up the story that talks
about Trump having hand cuts and you can
link to it they don't look like cuts to
me they look like
SCE and I've asked a number of MDS what
medical condition manifests itself
through hand sores and the answer is
immediate and unanimous secondary syphus
all right I think that I think there's a
good chance this man has to clap and I'm
not being particularly secretive about
it I am texting the photo you can link
to it it's in some operation called a
daily mail it's some British thing it's
probably a Fleet Street R ride but you
know maybe the picture was doctored or
whatever but I maybe this story will go
somewhere maybe it won't but I'm telling
you at 1:00 Eastern I'm humping this
thing like a young dog on old
[Laughter]
furniture one clock East I don't care if
it's a lie or not I'm going to hump this
thing like a young dog on old furniture
but I I do have to make a correction
yeah the clap is not syphilis the clap
is ganaria oh is it ganaria I thought it
was cyia no no no it's ganaria garia are
you sure are you sure about these things
yeah let me double check here I'm pretty
dude I remember my freshman my freshman
did you clap
no I thought you were gonna say my
freshman year I had the CL clean clean
clean oh okay all right it's my summer
going into my freshman year of high
school and I was like oh I'll take a
I'll take health class right I'll take
health class and I'll take some computer
class and I remember I will never forget
those images that they showed us of like
crazy blown out like you never treated
that type of
[__]
and the clap if I just feel like I'll
never forget that uh is ganaria yeah
here I look it up the ganaras STI uh
neria ghara or
ghus used to be known as the
clap why do they call the clap clap in
reference the word clapier which means
brothel a place where STD such as
gonorrhea can be transmitted it
describes an early treatment for ganara
in which the Clapping yeah so this is
the other one that I will never forget
is they would take two like wooden
boards or planks or like two heavy
objects okay this is going to be graphic
the reason that it's called the clap is
because you would
put a dude's penis in
between and clap it
together to get all of it out to get all
of it out all of it out
oh see you Clap the dick yeah that is
what that is why it's called the clap
and that is what I learned that is what
I learned my freshman year going into or
like some are going to freshman year and
I was like holy [__] this is [__]
rancid this is gross uh I never want
this to happen so you know hey safe sex
wear protection you know make sure your
partner's good don't end up like
Donald hey dude I've been calling this
out here let me I'm gonna pull up the
tweet
Baby You're gonna pull up the Tweet did
you tweet that he had cilis yeah man I'm
telling you yeah yeah man of course of
course I'm the most one of the another
famous person who who suffered from uh
late stage civilist is Al Capone yeah he
an actual an actual mobster an actual
and he died going
crazy uh yeah because syphilis like eats
your brain yeah well it becomes syphilis
well basically it'll attack you it'll
become neuros syphilis and that's where
Al Capone went crazy and it ate away his
brain um okay let August
22nd 2017 I brought this I brought this
clip back or this uh this Tweet back
because at the I went back and I was
like oh man nobody engaged with this
tweet at the time
really actually nobody did and then I
retweeted it and I said syphilis and
Trump are trending so I thought I would
dust this off and it's from August 22nd
2017 and basically there was a question
of people being like the Washington Post
was talking about Donald Trump's mental
health
right there it is 8:33 a.m. August 22nd
2017 I'm gonna say it's neurosifilis
Gabe Sanchez doubt him doubt him if you
must but you might it might be at your
own baril because um he's got he's got
the civilist I'm gon interact with this
right now oh yeah totally thank you uh
you have to look at it and you have to
say like this does doesn't make any like
how one person can can become the person
they are right now like how do they
become super susceptible vulnerable P
you know they can be persuaded they're
gullible their their mental capacity has
gone to [__] we know that he sleeps
around we know that he's probably not
the cleanest person we know his hygiene
he smells like [__] um he he's just a
he's a sar in general like he's the
human embodiment of a sore of an
STI and then the fact that he had it on
his hand and every was like oh and I was
like oh caught red-handed Donald Trump
with the
syphilis well speaking of him smelling
I've got a great song here from our our
buddy Tennessee Brando and it's called
downwind of Donnie and it specifically
refers back to some of these James carvo
Clips let's listen to downwind of Donnie
well I haven't written a song in quite a
while I've been kind of slacking but I
got the inspiration for this one after
watching a James caral video I call this
downwind to
Donnie down wind to Donnie there's a
hell of stench smelling like ketchup and
rotten armpits from the sound of his
diaper he sh
down there's a hell of yeeha he claims
to weigh in at
25 yet he's the biggest slob that we
ever have seen he says he's a perfect
specimen he never gets sick it's been 20
years and he still ain't seen his
dick
down there's a hell ofch smelling like
ketchup and rotten armpits and the sound
of his diaper he done took [__] oh
down there's a hell of a
stitch get down
[Music]
that's Tennessee Brando downwind of
Donnie in tribute of the winner bone
head of the week Donald Jessica Grandpa
civilist Grandpa Hitler Trump gab
Sanchez let's give him is
[Music]
[Applause]
due
[Music]
I so close close was close it was close
it was so close yeah they were the polls
on each one were complete opposite right
so oh so on disc Matt Gates it was
consistent Matt Gates got [__] yeah yeah
well he is [__] so that's not surprising
that's not surprising he is [__]
he's complete [__] [__] [__] [__]
yeah oh so you really do think it's
syphilis have have we confirmed rather
the the the it's doctored or not have we
no it's not doctored it's real real yeah
it's a real photo [__] is real this [__]
is real but uh I know that Alex Jones is
like hey man stop making fun of Donald
Trump for having syphilis he doesn't
have cilis I hate all these people that
are conspiracy theorists and they're
making [__] up and it's like oh from a
guy
honey coming from the guy who owes uh 1
point something billion dollars in
defamation for the Sandy Hook victim
families well listen I think some people
are saying that it's golfer's hand if
that's what you call this you know what
I mean I mean it's possible it could be
gol no there was a there was a you know
I did go through some possible scenarios
I was like well maybe he still had
marinara sauce from the pizzas that he
so so commandingly
carried oh my god did you see him he can
carry eight pizzas it's almost like RFK
Junior [__] pressing 90 pounds two
times God it's so
mly eight pizzas that's that's your
eight pizzas wow as he drags that leg
yes um so I thought I was like well
maybe it's maybe it's marinara sauce
maybe it's ketchup maybe maybe it is a
golfing thing but I was like for a guy
who's supposed to be as much and as
frequent as he does I haven't seen him
ever show his hands where he's got these
sores on him and we know that he's
currently obviously nowhere close to
Melania even today melan was like
there's the video of melan and and
Donald Trump and they had a quick
exchange as she got into the car the car
door was open he goes like
this and two separate cars my guy they
left in two separate cars from from the
whatever the funeral for her mother uh
two separate cars did not get in the car
we know that she lives down the hall in
a separate
room well Donald Trump maybe maybe you
know what maybe you know okay other
possibility other possibility no lube
you know getting very he's getting very
uh or they're not cousins they're not
cousins so um you know they don't yeah
you know they're not Cousin [__]
fascists don't go anywhere this is bone
the week don't go anywhere we're gonna
we're gonna talk a few more things I
want to show another video right after
this the song The
[Music]
[Applause]
Jingle bone head of the week it's Friday
Bon head of the week that's that's been
the song the entire time and we picked
that out originally we're like yeah it
needs to be like a needs to be kind of
like you know kidish because we're going
to make fun of these [__] when
we origin came up with bone we
I was looking I was looking through
tweets of me talking about Donald Trump
having syphilis because I've had
several
and and I haven't I haven't the last
time I think I talked about I said it in
2017 I talked about it in 2019 I talked
about in 2022 2021 anyway there was a
tweet of um actually it was some I quote
tweeted Brett back in July of 2021 and
he said [__] crazy and it said have
been vaccinated will get vaccinated and
it says Democrats 93% Republicans
49% and then somebody goes if it's not
real then what did their dear leader
catch and I said
syphilis so you've been on to him this
entire time I'm not sure how you know
that it's cilis I'm not sure how you
know this but look man I only know I
only know one time one time in college
just got to say okay excuse me okay very
rude let me finish okay did I didn't
tell her uh um the idea that the idea
that that that's stuff that I learned in
health in health class from the summer
going to my freshman year of high school
it was I will never forget it the images
that I had to see in that class were
[__] gross they were disgusting they
will I will always live with them seared
in your brain they're seared into your
brain they're seared into your brain
just like this will be seared into your
brain after you watch it because anyone
who doesn't think that he has syphilis
is nuttier than squirrel turds let's
listen well tell y'all the Cheeto
humping [__] nuggets are out in force
this morning geez o Pete I
mean this woman just sent me a message
saying that she's gonna quit following
me because I'm a Biden sheeple and she
didn't realize
it [__] where have you
been Jesus Christ you people are nuttier
and [__] squirrel turds get it
together you have three
granddaughters vote for their rights
pull your head out of your ass yeah
that's right that's what you need to do
right after you go over to Gabe
Sanchez's YouTube channel and follow him
youtube.com am gab Sanchez or I am gab
sanchez. then go register to [__]
vote go to register to vote make sure
you're voting for your daughters and
your granddaughters rights vote for
their [__] rights not against them
vot for him and engage in your democracy
one way to do it is come here every
single weekday every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours and
make sure to join us on Friday in the
second hour when the guy with the last
name Sanchez Jo us for Bon of the week
what do you got you got some excuse me
okay got it got an important
announcement here okay for the guy with
the last name Sanchez um starting next
week we are back on it what was that
what was that live is back is back back
back back Tuesday Wednesday back welcome
back
welcome Tuesday Wednesday Thursday at
5:00 pm Pacific 800 PM Eastern the show
will be back I got some work stuff that
I have during the mornings now so uh you
know gotta pay those bills baby
so Wednesday Thursday 5:00 p.m Pacific
8:00 P.M Eastern you will catch me on
the show those days same same way we did
it before we'll have an hour maybe a
little bit more you know maybe we get
things
going go to youtube.com gab Sanchez or I
am ganz.com you can also go let me show
you here you can go to the Tony
michaels.com let me show you this this
is really cool you just pan you just pan
all the way down here you go all the way
down and
then there it is everything Gabe Sanchez
Gabe Sanchez bought him yeah well you
know what are you gonna it's there go
there pan down go to everything Gabe
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez YouTube his twitch
Channel you can catch his show what was
that live next Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday at five
Pacific I got the right five Pacific 8m
Eastern five Pacific 800 p.m EAS Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday for one full hour and
then come here every single weekday
Monday through Friday new Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific same time same place
on Monday have a good weekend I'll see
you on the Sunday rant go to patreon
join sign up and you'll be able to come
watch it we'll see you on Monday Sur up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
[Music]
we have to communicate backward so let
me give you example you're looking at
the background all right I have three
years here one 1996 what 1999
1 20002 2003 it's a multiple choice what
is now Trump is fat okay he's really fat
they put on his physical he weighs 230
pounds I tell I'll make anybody this bet
Trump you get on the schedule scale and
every pound under 230 I'll pay you a
th000 if every pound over 230 you pay me
$10 and I'm going to bank so the the
question is what is the last year you
think that Trump actually saw his dick I
think it's 2000 I don't think he's seen
it in this Century remember the century
really doesn't start till January 1st
2001 it's kind of weird thing but I I
give the benefit of that that's what
that's how fat what a fat piece of [__]
I think
is